la preuve c'est qu'on va parler de
meghan markle et sa supposée mauvaise
influence sur harry le pic est d'arriver
dans la famille royale britannique on le
sait elle est au coeur de nombreuses
polémiques tout le monde était viré l a
pas fait la chasse à courre ta ta ta ta
ta et cette semaine eh ben on a appris
que ce dernier se serait éloigné de l'un
de ses meilleurs amis d'enfance à cause
d'une ancienne actrice
ils ont annoncé aussi que ça y est il
allé faire des maisons séparées et tout
ça guillaume dans la loge m'a dit je
reconnais il ya vraiment un problème
megan at elle une mauvaise influence sur
harry on regarde le sujet et puis après
devant la france entière tu pourras nous
présenter des excuses
le prince harry avait il vraiment avec
qui il se marier en ce jour béni du mois
de mai 2018
crazy harry comme on l'appelait à leur
éternel adolescent un peu fou fou un peu
pataud choisissait qu'une actrice
américaine au tempérament bien trempé
qui semaine après semaine semble bien le
mener à la baguette
[Musique]
comment pourrait-il savoir qu'après une
vaste opération de séduction familiale
même la reine la sueur qui fait dans les
premières semaines
mégane se révèlerait selon certaines
rumeurs manipulatrice et des penseurs
depuis l'annoncé de sa grossesse en
octobre dernier megan aurait dépensé au
bas mot 600 mille euros de frencq leur
visite officielle au maroc fin février
dernier ad'ailleurs virer au déballage
bling-bling allez on vous donne les prix
cette robe bleue fleury 3000 euros et
cette robe dior 100 miller
du coup l'un personnel de la princesse
lui a trouvé en sur la mégane ii vient
ni game la rafle de gains ça fait mal le
pompon c'est que le couple va bientôt
déménager il quitte kensington pour
fraude mort à 30 km de là la secure mamo
a demandé pour trois millions cinq cent
mille euros de travaux
on imagine déjà la rencontre avec
l'architecte alors là vous virer ces
vieux truc et je veux une piscine là le
liant baldaquin il dégage vous ne mettez
un jacuzzi et les escaliers ça serait
pas un peu plus classe aux canons du
couffo l'ascenseur aux mimiques tout ça
le pauvre prince semble quasi inexistant
alors mégane à thème une mauvaise
influence sur harry
je me frotte les babines
on a commencé vidéo par guillaume qui
forcément a des infos ensuite après une
petite pause publicitaire très courts et
puis ensuite on reviendra on aura les
avis des autres de ceux qui savent donc
du mougnan à l'anjougame donc nous
aurons une attelle mauvaise influence
j'ai répondu non parce que pour rester
droit même compter une erreur faut y
aller non aller sinon elle n'a aucune
mauvaise influence
partie 1 harry est le chouchou des
anglais harry est le chouchou de la
reine d'angleterre harry est un enfant
abîmé qui a avoué ya peu de temps être
tombé dans l'alcool dans qui s'est
jamais remis de la mort de sa mère et de
la brutalité de la presse sur lui et il
a une femme qui n'est pas une anglaise
qui est une américaine qui l'a rencontré
jusque là vous avez rêvé alors est ce
qu'elle est mauvaise a depuis trois ans
et qui lui dit juste mon chéri tu sais
quoi tu partait à vau l'eau
tu fus mais tu te droguer tu te faisais
n'importe quoi l'art et dans le budget
elle et elle elle le canalise elle le
calme elle elle lui fait faire des détox
elle l'emmène à la campagne alors trois
millions et demi de travaux en effet
parce que c'est dans leur logique des
co-responsables donc ça sur les gars
étaient mauvaises personnes qui toutes
tour les données pour sa belle virginie
elvire les mauvaises personnes savez
quoi c'est une américaine et donc du
coup quand elle veut dire je m'en vais
dire qu'avec un problème parce que oui
c'est vrai que entre elles et kate
il ya un problème et du coup ça influe
sur les frères mais elles peuvent pas
saquer jean ses frères ses loyers
ressort messieurs zh qui voulaient
décrocher le pactole mais pas du tout
parce qu'ils en disent un peu sigle
américaine plus une rizière comme la
mort chiant comme la mort quéquette
qu'est petite bourgeoise qui ne fait la
reine elle kiffe mégane pourquoi elle
type mégane parce qu'elle est enceinte
comme ça elle va au maroc
elle parle elle elle fait des
associations elles se bouge alors que
kate enceinte elle se faisait chier les
thés dansants qui pèse a été malade à
huy meghan markle est devenu un problème
aujourd'hui en angleterre sait pas on va
parler des stars qui empochent des
fortunes avec la presse people des
français français qui cartonne l
étranger ou qu'ils disent c'est souvent
le grand truc ça marche pas ici même ce
carton au nahd
enfant star hyper sexualisée donc ça
aussi c'est un sujet qui va beaucoup
beaucoup vous plaire je pense donc on
parlait de meghan markle et la question
était est-ce que megan est une mauvaise
influence sur harry guillaume a dit non
mais si vous avez été noués avec nous
avant mais c'était incompréhensible
c'est que t'as dit elle est brune elle
est sympa de 88 vous n'avez rien à dire
ce que dan geer jal a perdu ton tour tu
avais rien à dire mais dans votre sujet
avait plein de trucs je veux juste finir
par un seul truc on dit qu'elle
s'habille trop cher et que sa dépouille
et qu'elles dépensent trop bon cette
année on n'a même pas un an de mariage
elle ajuste alors oui le médium à 3002
et ça a rapporté un milliard à la
couronne britannique en france elle a
juste porter des boucles d'oreilles je
crois est celle qu'on voit là et alors
depuis l'entreprise française étant et
son carnet de commandes est plein
pendant deux ans parce que le monde
entier va donc on parle que d'argent qui
a la grâce d'allah galibert d'avril elle
rapporte de l'argent dont elle est maire
rapporte plus rien à ce qu'ils attaquent
zhiyong les deux frères s les deux les
deux frères ne peut plus à quai ils
étaient hyper liés depuis la mer lève la
mort de leur mère est la dirai tout le
monde des coutumes et les fous dehors
elles ramènent leurs burgers
elle est un peu vulgaire et à mon avis l
autre à tomber alors arrêtez de jouer
avec la petite couronne le rhône at il
alors pardon à quelqu un qu est-ce qui
est choqué choqué oui lui que j'aime
bien quand plus que qui fait des phrases
courtes et apte
non mais quelle qu'elles achètent des
fringues cher le droit les riches en
sont fous qu'elle refasse des travaux
c'est leur vie dépenser son pognon ça
fait travailler les entreprises c'est
très bien qu'elle sépare les deux frères
étaient unis justement depuis la mort de
leur mère depuis la mort de leur mère
c'est pas normal un ouf quelle crème
mauvaise femme au fond quelque part bien
sûr parce qu'elle ne veut que pour lui
elle va avoir élevé à voir sont
exactement garder elle ne pas qu'ils
aient plus son frère puisse être
meilleur ami et caetera et quelque part
elle rit elle ed naturel est le sort
complètement son contexte et c'est là
qu'elle est un peu entre le principe des
pervers c'est d'isoler les oui j'en
aurai parce que désolé de ce qui
l'entouré leur ai dit ça mais c'est la
totale on dit c'est le cas alors encore
dynamo pardon parce que tu parles
d'automne je crois que tu as été à
londres
une fois c'était en 70 nous avons à la
tête du pétrole il ya pas de feux rouges
états et non contre elle à l'aller denis
migani rien si j'habitais je suis allé
me qu'une gamme fin je connais
sébastien en revanche ce qui va et legs
et qui a éclairé les barbus avec les
capuches les gros là dont vous me parlez
qu'ils aimaient chez à londres dans les
cafés les paparazzi non là pour le coup
moi j'ai mes confrères anglais ouais là
il ya un vrai vrai problème est donc moi
j'attends de voir ce qui va se passer
quand le bébé va arriver et tout le
monde attend de voir justement le s'ils
vont venir et avec quelle tête ils vont
venir voir le bébé à l'hôpital parce que
ils sont vraiment fâché pour le moment à
ils sont vraiment faciles pour le moment
merci quand même deux arrivées à fâcher
deux frères qu'ils s'adoraient unis elle
a quand même réussi à me la mets
attendait mais à gaillac est aussi dans
l'histoire qui ont pardon je regardais
dernier mot elle et vous rendez pas
compte que tout ça peut être serré mais
elle est en train de sauver la couronne
britannique
il faut qu'on parle de ces gens là et
qu'est ce qu'on fait depuis septembre
ces sujets que l'on fait c'est sur
mégane kate est en train de
s'embourgeoiser avec william on n'en
parlerait pas ça n'intéresserait plus
percée phocéen elle sauve je suis désolé
non que ce soit en bien ou en mal et on
en parle c'est sympa mais bon c'est ça
l'important aujourd'hui est monté cinq
écoutez c'est bête que vous dites
britannique je suis défenseur du bad
buzz pour parler de quelqu'un je donne
la parole à berriane mais j'ai beaucoup
daniel mais pour le coup elle dit
n'importe quoi
non mais parce que en fait c'est faux ou
kate avant l'arrivée de megan on faisait
énormément progressé c'est fini
maintenant c'est pas pour rien en faire
jusqu'à des mauvais sondages mathieu je
trouve que vous êtes quand même tous
très misogyne à aucun moment vous êtes
tous mercredi
à aucun moment vous dit que si ça se
trouve mais il est peut-être très
content harry d'être l'homme voulait
justement faire un petit peu de ménage
au sein de la section 501 ce scénario
vous le l'envisager jamais bat tous
misent encore une phrase courte et
intelligente de sébastien voilà comme
ton sexe j'suis désolé ça montrera qu
est-ce qui viennent qu'est-ce qui
viennent dire ils voulaient oui il est
envisagé de se passer de son frère il
est intéressant il tient on est là
depuis le temps que j'ai envie de me
démarque en accuse toujours les femmes
d'être responsable du problème la scène
rock folk que ce que je suis et les usa
uk pas tous en même temps il a dû voir
un problème on semble dernièrement un
procès avec sa donc y placer un truc que
sondage des ennemis regardez un truc
mégane at elle eu une mauvaise influence
sur le prince harry
alors les gens pour former les gens
savent pas encore la vérité mais ça va
monter au fur à mesure de l'émission
alors les gens sont pas encore assez
informés mais maintenant elle mais
maintenant ils les sables à saint
sébastien et des gens qui travaillent
comme comme comme moi